[Musique]
le biomimétisme sait comment la nature
peut-elle nous inspirer pour pouvoir
travailler aussi bien quelle nature
c'est 3 milliard et demi de recherche et
de développement et tout ce que la
nature a fait a toujours été 100%
durable y'a jamais déchets déchets sa
nourriture pour un autre organisme tous
les l'ensemble du vivant collaborent
pour pouvoir fonctionner de manière à ce
que furent mesure que le temps passe le
système se perfectionne et plus stable
plus riches
beaucoup plus complet donc le
biomimétisme est pour moi l'exemple même
du comportement que nous vous devons
nous devons faire et puis le
biomimétisme a tellement de d'expérience
en durabilité qui nous nous apprendre
énormément de choses
regardons comment à biot béton effet
dans la nature la carapace d'un
coquillage par exemple c'est une
merveille d'ingénierie pour pouvoir
faire ce matériau ce petit mollusque va
aller chercher tout ce qu'il faut autour
de lui sans le déranger personne sans
aucune pollution au contraire ils
absorbent le co2 de nature a mis des
millions d'années a constitué et
commence un peu à réparer tout ce que
nous avons fait une bêtise dans notre
environnement
donc moi je suis complètement émerveillé
chaque fois que je regarde ce qui se
passe autour de moi dans un univers
naturel et j'essaye de comprendre
comment je peux faire pour agir mieux
plus proprement plus en phase avec tout
ce qui existe et pas en démolition et ça
me permet de donner la mesure de la
manière dont je dois faire les choses
comment est ce que je peux intervenir
sur un terrain en utilisant tous que
je peux comprendre de cycles naturels
d'écosystèmes de la coopération avec
l'ensemble du vivant et j'essaye chaque
fois d'utiliser tout ce que j'ai comme
maigres connaissances dans le domaine et
que je continue à cultiver à apprendre
et je cherche en fait à construire
intervenir dans un environnement en
perturbant le moins possible tout
déséquilibre qu'est la nature mis
tellement de temps à mettre en place
mais je suis je suis architecte et d'un
rôle d'architecte c'est toujours de
travailler dans le futur un architecte
dessine quelque chose qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui et qui existera dans deux
trois quatre cinq ans peut-être
c'est à partir de là je me suis dit
peut-être que je peux voir un peu plus
loin
imaginer quelque chose qui pourrait se
faire dans 100 ans et se dire mais
comment est-ce que quand on aura
développé des nouvelles techniques
appris de nouvelles choses
on pourrait être enfin plus en phase
avec la nature avec l'ensemble du vivant
et
j'essaye de voir quel pourrait être le
monde dans lequel j'aimerais que j'aime
a bien trouvé d'ici un siècle
ça me permet d'avoir l'idée du chemin
que je dois faire pour y arriver il se
fait qu'on manque singulièrement de
vision de deux là où nous devons aller
dans notre futur toutes les visions
qu'on nous montre son catastrophique
c'est évidemment pas la queue on a envie
d'aller mais qu'elle serait une bonne
solution c'est ça qui me pose comme
question
et moi je suis dessinateur je suis je
suis architecte d'une vision par des
images donc j'essaye de représenter le
monde dans lequel j'aimerais bien vivre
et je le fais avec mes moyens techniques
celui un peu de la bande dessinée de la
peinture etc
pour arriver à créer un univers dans
lequel j'invite les gens rentrés à venir
voir ce qui se passe à garder ce sept
autres possibles ce possible qui ne
serait pas celui d'une société de
consommation une société on accumule le
plus possible de bien où j'étais
énormément mais une société qui serait
en phase avec l'ensemble de la planète
mon inspiration vient surtout de
l'observation des écosystèmes un
écosystème 7
c'est un ensemble d'organismes vivants
qui coopèrent l'un avec l'autre pour
créer quelque chose qui
et qui est durable qui était stable qui
est organisé de manière à pouvoir
progresser avancer et se perfectionner
en ferrain mesure que le temps avance
quand on voit ce qui était la planète
au moment de l'apparition du vivant
c'était tout à fait simpliste quelques
parasites simplement offert un brio du
temps tout cela c'est de loin
perfectionner et multiplier bio
diversifiée il ya eu énormément de deux
nouveaux systèmes qui se sont mis en
place
et plus le temps passe plus le système
devient riche stable équilibré par une
intervenante a évidemment été comme ça
tu as vraiment c'est après une
catastrophe parce qu'on sait pas pour un
travail mal on travaille plus dans la
destruction que dans la construction et
porter son regard plus loin permet de
voir quelles sont les conséquences de ce
que l'on fait est qu'elles sont les
brumes mieux quelles sont les choses
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui si on veut
arriver à être un peu plus en phase avec
le cette planète qui nous a accueillis
avec tellement de générosité notre lui a
très mal rendu tout ce qu'elle nous a
offert
je ne pense pas que la ville future 204
de 2084 fonctionnera déjà comme un
écosystème
ce serait en tout cas formidable je ne
suis pas du tout optimiste suis pas
pompier passe pessimiste non plus ce
sont des préjugés je trouve
inintéressant moi je ne cherche pas à
montrer ce qui est le plus probable qui
se passe mais ce que je souhaiterais qui
se passe
quelques moments différents je ne
dessine pas la réalité je dessine ce que
j'aimerais bien voir arriver et je le
fais comme une proposition comme une
invitation à ce que on rentre dans une
idée qu'il y à un autre monde qui est
possible et que cet autre monde beaucoup
trop peu montré qu' on ne le partage pas
moi j'aimerais simplement le dé dire que
s'il est possible positifs sont
innombrables et quand on n'a pas
suffisamment conscience de toutes ses
possibilités et que si on peut prendre
conscience de tout ce qui a des moyens
de fait à nos magnifiques
peut-être qu'on pouvoir retrouver
confiance dans une pas un avenir que
nous avons nous avons tombé que tout le
monde mais n'en voit comme étant quelque
chose de tout à fait
catastrophique j'ai pas vraiment de
réponse à la question de savoir comment
pourrait intégrer l'informatique dans
dans la ville biomimétique hulu la ville
archi beau récente du futur mais pour
moi les normes rock avantage les progrès
qu'on a fait avec l'informatique c'est
surtout avoir accès à une connaissance
universelle à peu près n'importe où à
tout moment le le web est une
et une taxe est extraordinaire une
connaissance phénoménal donc là on a une
richesse énorme ça ça nous permet de
beaucoup mieux évoluer avancé voir les
conséquences les causes les moyens les
tout ce qui nous est mis à disposition
donc utilisé ou le pour nous enrichir
pour mieux apprendre qu elles sont
quelques euros nous avons à jouer
quelles sont les conséquences de nos
actes ici nous sommes dans un rôle tout
à fait exceptionnel on est la saline
d'arc-et-senans qui était conçu et
réalisé par nicolas ledoux juste avant
la révolution française 780 et c'est
devenu un haut lieu d'exposition
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité unesco
il ya des expositions d'été tout ce qui
se passe durant toute l'année et j'ai la
chance d'avoir été invité pour cette
année à ma montre et l'ensemble de mon
travail sur l'art chine hors essence sur
le site et végétales dont une exposition
ville devrait durer d'avril à octobre et
qui va occuper 2500 m² dans des
bâtiments qui se trouvent ici derrière
moi et l'ensemble des jardins qui font
le tour de des bâtiments ça s'est fait
en collaboration avec des étudiants
paysages qu'ils vont réaliser des
travaux sur le thème des cités végétales
et sept programmes hook était lancé pour
eux dans l'idée commence qui peut
s'inspirer des siens que j'ai réalisé
pour pouvoir faire des propositions
d'installation qui sont qui rentre dans
ce cadre là le doom qui ce qui se trouve
juste ici dans lequel on a fait une
partie de séquences filmées ont été a
été réalisée l'année dernière et l'année
d'avant par ses étudiants sur ce thème
là de la cités végétales et mais non ce
souterrain
on va l'utiliser comme centre de
recherches sur l'habitat vivant qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
en travaillant avec ce que la nature
nous offre comme matériau de
construction
on va faire un un carter c'est un une
habitation qui est fait à partir de
techniques de
mais on pourrait appareiller ville
madame de l'utilisation de chanvre avec
un peu de show et qui font des centaines
d'habitations un peu d'eau bits comme ça
qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont vraiment
fonds intéressante très imaginative très
très très très en phase avec la nature
parce que tout est pris directement dans
dans l'environnement pas très loin
on peut y aller toutes sortes de formes
ici on va faire une technique un petit
peu différente en effet sans sur une
ossature bois pour pouvoir atteindre des
dimensions un peu plus grand mais on va
expérimenter ce amènera d'autres après
donc cette le départ d'un endroit où on
pourrait faire de la recherche sur un
habitat dont l'ensemble éléments partir
est ce qu'on peut trouver dans un
environnement proche